[Music]
Health
Care
education
water nutrition there are so many
pockets of the world that still are in
extreme poverty I mean a billion people
living on a125 is wrong it's just wrong
and we got to do something about it all
of the things that lead to Poverty
alleviation come from economic growth
and we believe the entrepreneurs in
these economies are the engines of
growth we know that there are people out
there that can make this world a better
place and we want to get behind them
thanks to a generous gift from Bob Andy
King Stanford University is launching a
bold new initiative I think what the
gift allows us to do is it allows us to
think in much bigger terms about what it
is that we could do we are going to
create an Institute hous in The Graduate
School of Business to bring our
knowledge about entrepreneurship to
entrepreneurs who are trying to make a
better life it's called the Stanford
Institute for innovation in developing
economies The Institute has a long name
but we nickname it seed seed signifies
possibilities something small that has
the potential to grow it means hope seed
is going to include three components
research education and
dissemination and what we're calling an
on the ground component each part of the
Institute reinforces and supports the
others we will conduct research on how
to develop management skills and create
an entrepreneurial spirit in the
education and dissemination part of the
Institute we will develop courses for
our students courses for entrepreneurs
from developing economies and we will
take the knowledge that we have created
in the research arm of the Institute and
disseminated very broadly using the web
and information technology we also
recognize the need of collaboration with
underground people working with local
groups to make things happen engineering
students medical students business
students coming together to produce new
goods and services that don't exist now
and then we're going to take existing
entities from small size to much greater
size Stanford is a creature of Silicon
Valley and Silicon Valley is a creature
of Stanford and what is going to be able
to do which no one else has ever done is
to bring all that genetic code all that
secret sauce to the places around the
world that can benefit from it most it's
not just going to be a think tank it's
going to be results that uh it's going
to change people's lives this is one of
the largest gifts in Stanford's history
this is a very exciting opportunity it
is frankly for all of us the opportunity
of a
lifetime when I think of about seed and
I think about the opportunity to really
make a contribution we want to say thank
you I mean we can't do it ourselves but
I think Stanford University can do
it it's going to
[Music]
happen